I did not hit her it's not true it's
bullshit I did not hit her I did not
oh hi mark I love my eyes
hey what time
you thought the Star Wars reviews were
over nope so the force awakens is
finally in theaters throughout this
entire year since May I reviewed every
single Star Wars movie including force
awakens and there's one more that I
still have to talk about I mentioned
that I was going to have a surprise Star
Wars review for you guys and here it is
the Star Wars Holiday Special
the thing that George Lucas doesn't want
to be reminded exists here's an actual
quote from George Lucas if I had time
and a sledgehammer I would find every
single copy of the Star Wars Holiday
Special and destroy it there is no
official release of this thing everyone
involved with this wants to forget that
it ever happened Harrison Ford doesn't
always enjoy talking about the good Star
Wars movies ask him about this one he
might actually snap and kill you not any
one of my newer subscribers who doesn't
know of this segment called a hilarious
'ti review what it is is I review
something that such an atrocity it's
hilarious hilarious 'ti and the Star
Wars Holiday Special
definitely fits in that category this
thing came out on November 17 1978
everyone had Star Wars fever the first
film had just hit and someone somewhere
said hey let's cash in on that and let's
make it a holiday thing and release it
around Christmastime and let's have it
have nothing to do with Christmas
when you see something called the Star
Wars Holiday Special and it's coming out
right around Christmas time you
automatically think well there must be
Christmas in it no this is actually
about life day the big holiday on the
wookie planet and Han Solo trying to get
Chewie back home to celebrate life day
with his family what a great idea and
Harrison Ford's in it and Mark Hamill
and Carrie Fisher and like all of the
major stars of the original trilogy how
did this happen so this crappy
television special begins and there are
so many obvious shots taken directly
from the movie to try to up the quality
of what we're
looking at but if anyone had eyes and a
brain it's so obvious they're just
straight out of New Hope and Harrison
Ford really appears like he wants to be
there I mean when you look at this guy's
face you see someone who's having the
time of his life I mean he really really
wants to be in this TV special you know
it when you look at him and I got to be
honest I cried laughing seeing the
actors faces in the cheesy turn around
the camera smile Mark Hamill looking
like he just got spray-painted in some
sort of factory somewhere but watching
this movie I went through a series of
laughing at how hilarious it is like
this scene
and that hilarity went to pure shock at
many times over just moments in this TV
special whatever you want to call it
that had my mouth hanging open for long
segments a large majority of the Star
Wars Holiday Special is a Wookiee family
waiting for Chewie to come home to
celebrate life day and most of these
scenes are just these creatures growling
at each other with no subtitles and no
human characters there to tell us what
they're saying I also love how this
Wookiee home is clearly furnished from
the 1970s then starts a scene that lets
you win on what you're about to see the
entire thing we've already seen was
crappy but it was crappy in a watchable
way the following scene tells us what
the rest of this movie is going to be
like
two hours later
never fucking ends so poor mark hamill
shows up looking like a porcelain doll
did the director have to have him look
into frame it's so awkward after like
three minutes of him just staring at us
talking it's absolutely cringe-worthy
come on tomorrow let's see a little
smile
if that's better now an old dude and an
imperial officer look at a tiny aquarium
at this point I'm about 20 minutes into
this and I begin to question humanity
and oh my god they're gonna Road Darth
Vader - and by the way just so you know
those are actually cutscenes from a new
hope that didn't show up in the original
film and so glad they had them so they
could use him in this now one of the
Wookiees watches a cross-dressing cook
now today I'm going to be using the
tenderest cut of the bantha the loin the
loin is very tasty and serves for nicely
of course if your family has a hearty
appetite
I would suggest then that old popular
holiday favorite the Ben fer lump oh I'm
trying to figure out the goal here it
can't possibly be comedy was their goal
to make an assemblage of the most
unfunny ideas available and just plaster
the name Star Wars on it that's probably
what happened that would make sense
because around this time in the film
something occurred to me people made
this how does this happen
now we get some more inserted shots from
a new hope as Harrison Ford desperately
tries to appear as if he doesn't want to
flee the set now the old guy visits the
Wookiee house as everyone awaits
Chewbacca's arrival to give the older
wookie a virtual reality softcore porn
machine I'm actually not kidding at all
I'm getting your message are you getting
mine oh oh we are
we can have a good time
can't wait oh but just when you think
this scene couldn't get any worse
oh my god next we get Carrie Fisher
herself as Leia and c3po they're all
here this is why I'm reviewing it the
actual stars are in this movie it's a
thing that happened in real life that
Imperial patrol must be giving them more
trouble than we bargained for and that
line doesn't really make any sense think
about it this is more trouble than we
bargained for did you bargain for some
trouble but only a little bit of trouble
and it's a little bit more trouble than
you bargained for
it's like someone read the new hope'
script and was like oh they say bargain
for in it we'll put that in the holiday
special next in a possible scene that
could maybe be interesting in the
slightest storm troopers invade Chuy's
home and to distract them they show them
a machine that broadcasts a miniature
Jefferson Starship concert
now the kid watches a cartoon it's
probably the best part of this entire
thing at least we get an intro to Boba
Fett now you got the truss a main to you
to the new base this time we'll get them
all I see why they call you the best
bounty hunter sir engage but saying this
cartoon is the best part of the Star
Wars Holiday Special is like me finding
a rock inside of a piece of shit you're
like okay this is the one thing that's
not shit but it's just a rock the
animation for this though is atrocious I
mean right here Luke Skywalker looks
like he has friggin cocaine eyes han
Solo looks like he had a stroke and it
also doesn't make any sense
this wookie family was just speaking to
the real-life Luke Skywalker through
their weird skyped 1978 version and now
the little kid is watching a cartoon
featuring him it doesn't even make sense
within itself then he sits down and
watches an instructional video with a
malfunctioning droid I mean this shit is
just crazy it's it's not it's really
crazy like it's gonna make me go insane
a little bit I mean is this really
supposed to be funny
this entire movie is just people
watching video transmissions that's it
every single page of the script says now
here is where they sit down and watch
some sort of video etc etc etc now
there's a cantina scene within this
video stream the troopers are watching
it a man with a volcano head professes
his love for a bartender could they have
possibly attempted to make at least one
compelling scene anything just one next
time you're driving friend try stopping
by Greg and oh my god she started
singing again oh my gosh they finally
made it home han and chewie have made it
back for life day there's one more
stormtrooper who cares
Harrison Ford throws him off the roof
the best part is Hahn being a cute
father figure and next there's the most
Awkward hug in film history
so now chewy can finally celebrate life
day whatever that is oh no no no no no
no no you a bag they hold up snow globes
and then there's more acid trippy scenes
and the entire original cast comes back
and guess what happens
peace
a day of
me
a day
I we all can share
the tour
Oh
a day
the door
two three
Oh God I can't remember the last time I
had more of a feeling of relief
when the end credits played help guys
those are my thoughts on this Star Wars
Holiday Special
it is truly something to be seen but
it's definitely something you can't
unsee guys thank you so much as always
for watching that is the end of my Star
Wars reviews for the year of 2015 I had
an amazing time bringing these to you
guys and I would like to continue doing
more hilarious 'ti reviews I haven't
done enough of them I've gotten your
requests I'm hearing you I'm there for
you I'll bring them guys thank you so
much as always for watching be sure to
check out all of my other Star Wars
reviews available in my Star Wars
playlist on my home channel check them
out guys thank you so much and if you
like this you can click right here and
get steppen eyes